dans tous les quartiers du pays
ils cognent aux portes depuis des mois
les mousses qui vancouver calgary des
candidats aux élections fédérales parle
aux électeurs afin de connaître leurs
préoccupations et obtenir leur appui
pendant que cet échange là d'une autre
personne dont le travail est de relever
un certain nombre d'informations qu'il
observe
est ce qu'on observe qu'il ya des jouets
dans l'entrée est ce qu'il ya des
animaux dans la maison si la télévision
ou la radio joue relever ce qui est
écouté
donc c'est très intrusif en tête pour
les partis politiques
les données des citoyens sont des
ressources à exploiter des données sont
devenus le nerf de la guerre électorale
permettant partie d'identifier leurs
sympathisants et d'influencer les
indécis mais à l'ère numérique
jamais autant de données sur les
électeurs n'auront était à la portée des
politiciens et jamais les risques de
dérapage n'auront été aussi grand
[Musique]
nous avons voulu savoir ce que collecte
les partis politiques canadiens à notre
sujet nous avons demandé aux libéraux
conservateurs et aux néo-démocrates de
montrer leurs pratiques de collecte et
d'analysé des données mais ils nous ont
tous refusé l'accès il ya une chape de
silence autour des pratiques numériques
des partis politiques
le professeur thierry giasson a
rencontré de façon confidentielle des
stratèges deux parties dans le cadre de
ses recherches sur le marketing
politique
on nous espionnent on nous surveille on
collige dans l'information sur nous et
on utilise cette information là parfois
dans notre intérêt est parfois pas dans
notre intérêt et les partis politiques
dont aucun intérêt nous expliquer sa
part l'algérie contrairement aux grands
partis les verts eux se montrent un peu
plus ouverts à divulguer leurs secrets
ah ça c'est une maison verte des villes
mono est candidat pour les verts dans la
région de victoria en colombie
britannique
il a accepté de nous montrer comment se
fait la collecte de données dans sa
circonscription
les bénévoles qui sont sortis à qui son
clip qui sont allé frapper aux portes
ramène les données ici et puis on est un
vrai on sait qui nous appuient qui nous
appuient pas avec qui on devrait
communiquer plus tard
jo nous avons d'être vert d'événements
yeux étaient rouges candidat libéral aux
dernières élections et militants du
parti pendant plus de trente ans il a
quitté les libéraux après la décision du
gouvernement trudeau d'acheter l'oléoduc
trans martin
l'événement ne a compris le rôle crucial
qu'elle ait joué les données en
politique dès 2006 en côtoyant de jeunes
militants libéraux de la région de
victoria parmi eux un jeune génie de 16
ans christopher lee celui même qui
allait devenir le lanceur d' alerte au
coeur du scandale cambridge analytica où
les données personnelles de millions
d'utilisateurs de facebook ont été
utilisés pour influencer les électeurs
en faveur du break si tu es dedans notre
joie
en 2006 où aller un site déjà les
libéraux à faire l'utilisation de
données provenant des réseaux sociaux
selon d'événements d'un flacon est un
gars brillant jeune c'est un des
premiers dans le parti libéral à
comprendre il faut bouger là dessus sur
les données tu t'es un gars qui qui
voyait où les choses se diriger et puis
voulait que le parti libéral comprennent
aussi embarqué et si on le faisait pas
on aurait de vrais problèmes à
concurrencer avec les conservateurs mais
la direction du parti libéral à ottawa à
l'époque se montrent peu intéressés par
les suggestions christopher wild
contrairement aux libéraux les
conservateurs de stephen harper
n'hésitent pas à se lancer dans la
course aux données dans son livre
shopping four vote
la journaliste suzanne de la courte
révèle comment les conservateurs font
l'achat de données de consommation pour
cibler des électeurs non un conservateur
on a découvert que les propriétaires de
motoneige sont plus susceptibles
d'appuyer les conservateurs ils ont donc
acheté des listes d'abonnement de
magazines de motoneige afin de cibler
des électeurs conservateurs potentiel
bah ouais je veux remercier le conseil
canadien des organismes de mon tournage
d'un pays ils forment le gouvernement et
annonce des sentiers de motoneige les
conservateurs utilisent une base de
données appelée sims ou toutes les
informations recueillies au sujet des
électeurs sont consignés y compris
qu'ils appuient le parti et qui lui est
réfractaire
grâce aux données colligées dans sims
des stratèges conservateurs en ontario
cible des électeurs qui ne les a fuis
pas lors des élections de 2011 des
conservateurs leur envoi de faux
messages téléphoniques d'élections
canada indiquant erronément que leur
bureau de scrutin a changé
à la même époque un autre dérapage des
conservateurs soulève la controverse en
le montréalais rémy nassar c'est une
pétition implorant le ministre de
l'immigration d'intervenir en faveur de
réfugiés qui est menacé d'expulsion
on enseigne beaucoup des pétitions dans
la vie surtout là avec internet c'est
tellement plus facile
puis on prend pour acquis qu on met
notre adresse courriel puis c'est juste
là que ça s'en va mais eux non plus tard
il a la surprise de recevoir un courriel
de jason kenny le ministre de
l'immigration de l'époque faisant
l'éloge des efforts des conservateurs à
l'endroit des réfugiés qui est lesbienne
son identité et même son orientation
sexuelle ont été récupérés dans la base
de données d'un parti qui n'a jamais
appuyé
venus ont été classés comme lgbt ou du
moins sympathisants à cette cause là
jean classement qui n' a pas été fait
sur une base volontaire fait pas quelque
chose auquel on a nécessairement
consenti on a juste signé une pétition
pour aider quelqu'un ou une cause les
libéraux et après une humiliante défaite
en 2011 se rendent à l'évidence qu'ils
sont en train de perdre la guerre des
données il effectue un virage majeur
[Applaudissements]
les libéraux créer une catégorie de
sympathisants qui n'auront pas à payer
les frais d'adhésion partie mais en
revanche il doit vivre et quelque chose
d'encore plus précieux des informations
personnelles à leur sujet et puis ça
réussit je pense que de mémoire on en a
eu trois cent mille membres à la fin de
la course à la chefferie
alors ça vraiment marché en termes de
d'aller récolter des données
les libéraux achètent des outils de
collecte de données du parti démocrate
américain et adopte les méthodes qui ont
fait le succès du président barack obama
le génie de l'équipe obama a était
d'amasser les données de facebook creuse
les données sur les réseaux sociaux sont
primordiales pour les stratèges par
exemple qui sont vos amis où vivez-vous
quels sont vos intérêts tout cela
influence le vote et les gens publient
volontairement ces informations sur
facebook pendant la campagne électorale
de 2015
des vêtements neufs et candidat du parti
libéral sur l'île de vancouver lui et
tous les candidats libéraux du pays ont
alors accès à un nouvel outil de
collecte de données sur leurs tablettes
et leur téléphone intelligent une
application appelée mini vans
c'est un très bon système qu'ils ont ça
a coûté des millions on allait à une
porte on pouvait voir l'adresse noms des
personnes qui sont là les informations
qui avaient déjà été recueillis par le
passé et puis l'autre chose qui était
très important c'est que pendant la
conversation on pouvait entrer les
données même en arrivant à la porte on
pouvait voir boris qu'ils ont des
enfants il ya des jouets c'est fini
si tutu aussi d'observer la communauté
ethnique de la personne mais
scientifique désiré il ya certaines
communautés qui ont plus tendance à
voter libéral d'autres qui ont plus
tendance à voter conservateur et c'est
utile à savoir les canadiens ont choisi
le changement
un vrai changement
en 2015 les libéraux remporte une
majorité une victoire que peu avaient
prédit en début de campagne attribuables
en partie ou données recueillies sur les
électeurs ils savaient exactement quelle
circonscription était en jeu et où ils
devraient concentrer leurs ressources
à cette époque tout le monde se vantait
de leurs données et comment savait s'en
servir la controverse de cambridge
analytica a changé les perceptions
sommes à facebook
sanhouidi km/h tout d'un coup facebook
est devenu une entreprise obscures dans
l'esprit des gens est le président de
facebook sommait de s'expliquer dans la
foulée du scandale facebook
les libéraux se retrouvent sur la
sellette en raison d'un contrat de 100
mille dollars avec christophe le wali le
lanceur d alerte qui travaillait pour
qu'un bridge analytique a while using
the approach to grow par six thèmes
québec au fédéral les partis sont sortis
très vite pour montrer patte blanche et
dire écoutez nous nos pratiques elles
sont respectueuses et surtout on a
beaucoup entendu nous n'utilisons que
des données qui nous sont transmises va
long terme
les données recueillies par les partis
sont elles vraiment transmises
volontairement par les électeurs pour en
avoir le coeur net
j'ai demandé aux principaux partis
politiques de me fournir toutes les
données qu'il possède à mon sujet y
compris les analyses et la cote depuis
au parti qui m'a été attribué après la
pause on vous explique comment les
partis politiques consulte votre
facebook pour trouver ceux qui pensent
comme vous
[Musique]
en juillet dernier le candidat des verts
des v demain ne et son briquet de
bénévoles par contre les rues d'un
quartier d'espoir mort en colombie
britannique
est ce qu'il ya une possibilité que vous
voterez vert qu'est ce que vous pensez
ses bords
merci beaucoup pour votre avis
j'apprécie énormément mon fai est ici et
puis on fait les deux bords de la rue on
est très spécifique sûr qu'il faut avoir
le nom et c'est très bon d'avoir un
numéro de téléphone ou le courrier
si on peut avoir plus de données ça nous
donne un grand avantage
la journée de l'allergie d'événements
dont un ancien libéral fait mettant
campagne sous la bannière du parti vert
du canada un parti beaucoup plus
sensible aux questions associées à la
vie privée au sein du parti vert il ya
comme un malaise il ya un sentiment
parmi certains que on ne veut pas
recueillir des données
je vois ça comme un vrai problème pour
gagner et puis moi je viens de l'école
où il faut avoir des données alors il
faut trouver l'équilibré entre les deux
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que vous prendriez en
attendant on mettrait probablement
quand vous prenez les choses en notre
qu'est ce qui détermine si vous allez
demander le consentement quoi ils voient
qu'on prend des notes
ils savent qu'on est une équipe
politique alors on prend pour acquis un
consentement mais on ne demande pas
chaque fois ci on peut prendre des notes
parce qu'ils nous voient promenade et si
son objection on s'arrête immédiatement
notre prochaine arrêt est à victoria la
capitale de colombie-britannique
ici chaque électeur la province peut
obtenir les informations détenues à son
sujet par les partis politiques
provinciaux
c'est la seule juridiction au canada où
les parties sont soumis à une loi sur la
protection de la vie privée
il n'y a pas de loi sur la façon dont
les partis politiques hamas et analyse
les données au canada sauf ici en
colombie britannique
beaucoup de gens seraient surpris et
outré d'apprendre ça nous avons montré
au commissaire à la vie privée de la
colombie-britannique des images du
porte-à-porte que nous avons tourné avec
les verts fédéraux même ce parti
pourtant soucieux de la vie privée
n'obtient pas toujours un consentement
clair des électeurs
les lecteurs ne voit pas le bénévole
prendre des notes
donc il pourrait ne pas le savoir les
partis politiques devraient demander à
l'électeur est ce que nous pouvons
prendre en note des renseignements
michael mais que vaut et a récemment
effectué une enquête sur les pratiques
des partis politiques de la province
le plus gros problème est l'absence de
consentement des électeurs lors de la
cueillette et l'analyse des données
qu'elle s'interdit le consentement est
au coeur de tout ceci
les partis politiques peuvent quand même
continué de faire certaines analyses de
données
ils n'ont qu'à demander la permission à
l'électeur ce qui n'est pas trop
difficile dans la plupart des cas
dans son rapport d' enquête le
commissaire sommes les parties de
changer leurs pratiques particulièrement
concernant les réseaux sociaux la
démocratie en colombie britannique s'est
pas s'est pas effondrée et les partis
politiques en colombie-britannique
accepte de fonctionner dans un régime
qui plus contraignant comment les
parties de la colombie-britannique
fonctionne-t-il dans ce nouveau régime
stéphane johnson et le directeur des
communications du parti vert provincial
l'impact sur notre parti a été important
parce que les données sont au coeur de
tout ce que nous faisons
l'intégration avec les médias sociaux
est la plus importante activité que nous
avons c'est 100 auparavant
un simple j'aime cliquez sur des
publications du parti vert sur facebook
ou sur twitter suffisait pour que le nom
d'usager et parfois l'adresse de
courriel soit enregistrée dans leur base
de données
il est impossible de consentir à cela
nous avons désactivé toutes ses
fonctions le jour de la publication du
rapport du commissaire à la vie privée
qui a identifié cette pratique comme
étant problématique
nous allons supprimer toutes ces données
les méthodes de cueillette proscrite en
colombie-britannique sont pourtant au
coeur de la campagne fédérale actuelle
un des outils les plus populaires auprès
des partis politiques et la fonction
look like de facebook
le parc ci fournit à facebook les noms
d'usagers ou les adresses de courriel
d'un échantillon d'électeurs favorables
à ces politiques
facebook peut ensuite identifié une
quantité phénoménale d'utilisateurs qui
ont des profils semblables aux électeurs
de l'échantillon grâce à ses algorithmes
les algorithmes sont gardés secrets mais
il aurait accès aux messages privés et à
tout ce qu'on écrit sur ces plateformes
je suis certain que ça peut aller
jusqu'aux lieux de résidence ce qu'on
publie qui sont nos amis et quelles sont
nos intérêts politiques
bien que facebook mais tiennent
l'anonymat des utilisateurs ayant un
profil similaire
il permet aux parties leur envoyer de la
publicité ciblée
c'est comme la magie parce qu'on peut
rejoindre tellement de monde avec si peu
d'efforts on utilisait la fonction look
like de facebook mais on arrêter cette
pratique
cela démontre bien pourquoi on a besoin
de lois comme celles de la colombie
britannique où fédéral parce que les
partis ne vont pas s'auto réglementée à
ottawa les représentants du parti
libéral et du parti conservateur ne sont
pas chauds à l'idée d'être assujetti à
une loi sur la protection de la vie
privée
le parti au pouvoir qui forment le
gouvernement en ce moment au fédéral
c'est le parti libéral du canada
ils tirent un bénéfice claire de l'usaj
de ces données là alors ils sont en
conflit d'intérêts les partis politiques
sur cette question
la seule mesure adoptée par le
gouvernement libéral
c'est d'obliger les parties à mettre sur
leur site web
leur politique d'utilisation des données
mais selon le commissaire à la
protection de la vie privée du canada
daniel terriens c'est loin d'être
suffisant dans la loi il n'y a aucune
exigence contours compte de ces
politiques de vie privée donc les
pratiques peuvent y mettre n'importe
quoi et surtout la personne d'
indépendants pour aller vérifier que les
politiques sont véritablement mise en
place la ministre responsable des
institutions démocratiques estime qu'une
éventuelle loi encadrant les partis
politiques devra être différente de la
loi actuel régissant ce secteur privé ne
devrait en prendre un contexte la
différence entre un parti politique est
une une entreprise privée parce qu il y
a deux bouts différent je crois qu'après
les prochaines élections nous pourrions
étudier encore plus sains du nord
je ne comprends pas pourquoi ils ont
besoin d'étudier la question davantage
il ya sept ans le commissaire à la vie
privée et le directeur général des
élections de l'époque ont commencé à
sonner l'alarmé
9 on n'a plus besoin d'études mais la
côte ouest pourrait bien forcer la main
d'ottawa
le commissaire à la vie privée la
colombie britannique vient de statuer
que les partis politiques fédéraux
actifs dans la province doivent se
conformer à la loi provinciale sur la
vie privée
cette ordonnance pourrait forcer les
partis fédéraux a complètement revoir
leurs pratiques
et qu'en est-il de ma démarche pour
obtenir mes données personnelles
le parti populaire de maxime bernier le
parti vert et le parti libéral ont
répondu à ma demande dix ans boit peu ou
pas d'informations à mon sujet les
conservateurs et le npd n'ont même pas
répondu à ma demande
c'est une ressource qui nous appartient
que l'on que l'on offre aux partis
politiques mais les partis politiques
doivent nous permettre de la récupérer
c'est pas une ressource qu'on leur donne
indéfiniment notre vie privée nous
donner nous c'est ça nous appartient
notre personnalité numérique
elle nous appartient
[Musique]